D
THAT DAY ALL THAT'S HAPPENED
SAYS.
SOME OF IT IS TOUGH TO WATCH.
RANDI KAYE REPORTS.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
YESTERDAY, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES INCITED AN ARMED
INSURRECTION AGAINST AMERICA.
>> IN THE HOURS AFTER THE
ATTACK ON THE U.S. CAPITAL ON
JANUARY 6TH, 2021.
DEMOCRATS MOVE SWIFTLY TO TRY
TO REMOVE DONALD TRUMP FROM
POWER >> I JOINED THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER IN CALLING ON
THE VICE PRESIDENT, TO REMOVE
THIS PRESIDENT.
BY IMMEDIATELY INVOKING THE
25TH AMENDMENT.
>> MUCH SO THERE IS THIS MAY,
AND THEN VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE, REJECTED THE IDEA OF
USING THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
SAYING, IT WOULD SET A TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT --
CAN YOU SPEAK UP FORCEFULLY
AGAINST WHAT HAPPENED?
TODAY THAT >> IT IS HEARTS
DEMOCRATS AND RAPIDLY MOVING
AHEAD WITH THE SECOND
IMPEACHMENT OF DONALD.
TRUMP >> CLAUSE FOUR SOLUTION
24.
>> ON JANUARY 13TH, ONE WEEK
AFTER THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
THE HOUSE VOTED TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP.
>> HE MUST GO.
>> THERE WAS SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT.
TEN HOUSE REPUBLICANS VOTED TO
IMPEACH.
AND LATER, DURING THE SENATE
TRIAL.
SEVEN REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
STILL, TRUMP WAS ACQUITTED.
>> WHAT WE SAW MATT SENATE
TODAY, WAS A COWARDLY GROUP OF
REPUBLICANS.
>> DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
CAN DO GOOD, WORK TOGETHER.
>> BY MAY 2021, MANY MEMBERS
FROM BOTH PARTIES HAD AGREED ON
THE NEED FOR A BIPARTISAN
INDEPENDENT 9/11 STYLE
COMMISSION.
TO INVESTIGATE JANUARY 6TH.
THE PLAN WAS TO HAVE AN EQUAL
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS INVESTIGATING.
BUT, SOON REPUBLICANS
MISCHARACTERIZED THE EFFORT.
AND BALL.
>> I MADE THE DECISION TO
OPPOSE THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS --
UNBALANCED PROPOSAL.
.
FOR ANOTHER COMMISSION TO STUDY
THE EVENTS OF JANUARY THE 6TH.
>> SO, HOUSE DEMOCRATS FORMED A
SELECT COMMITTEE TO
INVESTIGATE.
WHICH INCLUDING REPUBLICANS LIZ
CHENEY AND ADAM KINZINGER.
BOTH OF WHOM HAD VOTED TO
IMPEACH TRUMP.
THE FIRST PUBLIC HEARING WAS IN
JUNE LAST YEAR.
>> AS AMERICANS, WE ALL HAVE A
DUTY TO ENSURE THAT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> FOR MANY, THE HEARINGS FOR
CTV.
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR TESTIFIED.
>> I DIDN'T AGREE WITH THE IDEA
OF SAYING THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN, AND PUTTING OUT THE
STAFF.
I TOLD THE PRESIDENT WAS BLEEP.
>> THIS IS THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER, TRUMP'S DAUGHTER
IVANKA TOLD THE COMMITTEE THAT
SHE AGREED WITH BARR'S
SUMMATION.
>> IT AFFECTED MY PERSPECTIVE.
I RESPECT ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR.
SO, I ACCEPTED WHAT HE SAID
WHAT --
>> FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
AIDE CASSIDY HUTCHINSON WAS
PERHAPS THE COMMITTEE STRONG AS
WITNESSES.
>> HIS RESPONSE WAS TO SAY THEY
CAN MARCH TO THE CAPITAL.
--
>> SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF,
TAKE THE BLEEP AWAY, THEY'RE
NOT HERE TO HURT ME LET THE MAN,
LET MY PEOPLE.
AND >> THE COMMITTEE SUBPOENAED
MANY IN THE ORBIT.
>> WE'RE GONNA HAVE JET --
>> CHIEF TRYING TO JUST STEVE
BANNON AND ADVISOR PETER
NAVARRO, OR BOTH CHARGED FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY.
BANNON WAS CONVICTED A TRIAL.
NAVARRO PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
AND IS AWAITING TRIAL.
THE COMMITTEE ALSO SAYS THAT
MORE THAN 30 WITNESSES TOOK THE
FIFTH DURING QUESTIONING.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE VIOLENCE
ON JANUARY SIX WAS JUSTIFIED
MORALLY?
>> I PLEAD THE.
FIFTH >> GENERAL FLYNN, DO YOU
BELIEVE IN A PEACEFUL
TRANSITION OF POWER IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
>> I PLEAD THE FIFTH.
>> FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS REFUSED TO TESTIFY.
AND PENCE RESISTED COOPERATION.
ALL THE WHILE, REPUBLICANS
SLAMMED THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WERE BEING PARTISAN.
>> THOSE IN FAVOR WILL SAY, I.
>> I.
>> IN OCTOBER, THE COMMITTEE
FORMALLY ISSUED A SUBPOENA TO
DONALD TRUMP.
>> WE'RE OBLIGATED TO SEEK
ANSWERS DIRECTLY FROM THE MAN
WHO SET THE SOLID MISSION.
>> TRUMP RESPONDED TO THE
SUBPOENA ON SOCIAL MEDIA ASKING,
WHY DIDN'T THE AND SELECT
COMMITTEE ASKED ME TO TESTIFY
MONTHS AGO.
HE CALLED THE COMMITTEE A TOTAL
BIASED.
THAT FURTHER DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY.
>> EXACTLY --
>> THE COMMITTEE LATER WITHDREW
THE SUBPOENA, AND TRY TRUMP
NEVER TESTIFIED.
>> STILL, THE COMMITTEE
UNCOVERED DISTURBING DETAILS
FROM INSIDE THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE.
AS THE CAPITAL WAS UNDER SIEGE.
IT HIGHLIGHTED 187 MINUTES OF
TRUMP'S INACTION DURING THE
ATTACK.
SHOWING HOW HE REMAINED IN HIS
PRIVATE DINING ROOM WASHING
COVERAGE ON FOX NEWS, FOR MORE
THAN THREE HOURS.
DESPITE PRESSURE TO PUT OUT A
STATEMENT, CALLING OFF THE
RIOTERS.
>> NOTHING BUT THE.
TRUTH >> THE COMMITTEE ALSO
REVEALED HOW A TRUMP FUNDED
LAWYER, ALLEGEDLY PRESSURED
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON NOT TO BE
TRANSPARENT WITH THE COMMITTEE
DURING HER TESTIMONY.
AFTER A 17 MONTH INVESTIGATION,
AND MORE THAN 1000 WITNESSES.
THE JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE JUST
LAST MONTH ANNOUNCED CRIMINAL
REFERRALS TO THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> WE'VE GONE WHERE THE FACTS
IN THE LAW LEAD US.
AN INESCAPABLE, A THEY LEAD US
HERE.
>> THE COMMITTEE REFER DONALD
TRUMP TO THE DOJ, FOR POTENTIAL
CHARGES RELATED TO FOR CRIMES.
>> ASSISTING ARE AIDING AN
INSURRECTION, CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES.
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, AND CONSPIRACY TO
MAKE FALSE STATEMENTS.
>> HE'S UNFIT FOR ANY OFFICE.
>> A CRIMINAL REFERRAL WAS ALSO
MADE FOR TRUMP'S LAWYER JOHN
EASTMAN.
WHO COULD FACE CHARGES OF
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING.
AND CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES.
EASTMAN SAYS, THE REFERRAL
CARRIED LITTLE WEIGHT.
BECAUSE IT WAS THE PRODUCT OF A
PARTISAN PROCESS.
RANDI KAYE, CNN.
>> WHILE, TWO YEARS IT'S BEEN.
AND JOINING US CNN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND FORMER
--
ANDREW MCCABE.
AND SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT JAMIE
GHANDOUR.
JAMIE, THE DUALITY OF THIS
JANUARY --
TWO YEARS AGO.
, OBVIOUSLY VERY DIFFERENT
DAYS.
SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE
INVOLVED ON BOTH DAYS.
I WONDER WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
WERE SEEING THAT CEREMONY TODAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE?
>>, WHILE IT WAS QUITE A SPLIT
SCREEN.
SEEING THE PEOPLE BE HONORED,
AND THEN THIS IS I THINK DAY
FOUR OF THE CHAOS CAUCUS.
WATCHING THOSE PICTURES, IN
RANDY'S PIECE, BRINGS IT ALL
BACK.
AND THEN YOU COMPARE THAT TO
WHAT WE SAW THIS WEEK.
A FORMER REPUBLICAN SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
ANDERSON, I'LL LET YOU GUESS
WHICH.
ONE SAID TO ME THIS WEEK AS HE
WATCHED WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE.
QUOTE, THE SUICIDE SQUAD IS
LOCKED AND.
IT'S LIKE WATCHING SOMEONE BURN
DOWN THEIR OWN HOUSE.
BECAUSE THE FLAMES EXCITE THAT.
HOW WILL WE GET HERE, AFTER
WHAT WE WENT THROUGH.
ON JANUARY 62 YEARS AGO.
IT IS JUST ASTONISHING TO ME.
>> ANDREW, DO YOU THINK
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY SAFER THAN
IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO?
>> WELL, ANDERSON, I WISH I
COULD SAY THAT I FELT
CONFIDENTLY THAT WE ARE.
BUT I'M NOT SURE, TO BE
PERFECTLY HONEST.
IN THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BY
THE COMMITTEE, AND BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF, THE FBI, AND
THEIR PARTNERS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY, THE
BIGGEST GAP FOR ME IS THAT WE
STILL HAVEN'T ANSWERED SOME
REALLY FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY HANDLES THE
INTELLIGENCE THAT LED UP TO AND
FORESHADOWED THE ATTACK THAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH.
THE COMMITTEE REALLY JUST GAVE
THAT A VERY, VERY MINIMAL KIND
OF GLANCING BLOW.
AND THEIR CONCLUSION TO THAT
MONSTROUS REPORT.
I HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH FROM THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES, WE
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE
FBI ABOUT AN INTERNAL REVIEW
THAT TO ASSESS THE PERFORMANCE.
WELL COULD ONLY BE QUALIFIED AS
PERFORMANCE FAILURES ON AN
ESSENTIAL MISSION PREVENTING
ACTS OF TERRORISM IN THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
THE PROCESS TO UNCOVER, TO
REEVALUATE WHAT THEY KNEW, WHAT
SORT OF INTELLIGENCE
ASSESSMENTS DECISIONS AND
COMMUNICATIONS THEY DID WITH
THAT KNOWLEDGE.
SO, I WISH I CAN SIT HERE TWO
YEARS LATER AND SAY, YEAH,
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE
LESSONS.
ARE AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT A
LOT ENFORCEMENT, INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITIES ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
BUT AT THIS POINT, WE STILL
REALLY DON'T KNOW.
THAT >> JAMIE, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO'S ALLEGEDLY
RUNNING AGAIN.
THOUGH, HE STILL SEEMS TO BE --
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> HE'S ANNOUNCED.
>> HE HAS ANNOUNCED.
DOES HE STILL HAVE THE POWER
THAT HE WILL INSTEAD?
AMONG REPUBLICANS?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
BECAUSE IT WAS FASCINATING TO
SEE FRANKLY WHAT APPEARED TO BE
HIS LACK OF INFLUENCE THIS
WEEK.
IT'S CERTAINLY LIVED PICK --
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
YES, HE ENDORSED KEVIN
MCCARTHY.
BUT IT WAS SORT OF TEPID.
HE SEEM TO BE WAITING TO SEE
WHICH WAY THE WIND WAS BLOWING.
TODAY STARTED MAKING CALLS
UNTOLD.
BY OUR COLLEAGUE KAITLAN
COLLINS, THAT ONCE IT LOOKED
LIKE KEVIN WAS GONNA GET A, I
THINK THE QUESTION THOUGH IS,
ISN'T WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
SPEAKER VOTE, OR WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE SPEAKER
ABOUT, IT'S WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
IN THE PRIMARIES.
IT'S WHO ELSE IS GONNA GET IN
THE RACE.
THEN YOU ARE REALLY GOING TO
KNOW, AS HIS INFLUENCE DIMINISH
SOMEWHAT, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WILL IT MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AT THE POLLS.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SAYS THAT 140 OFFICERS WERE
INJURED ON JANUARY.
65 OFFICERS DIED IN THE MONTHS
AFTER THE RIOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE LEGACY OF
THE INSURRECTIONAL BEFORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVES?
>> I HOPE THAT WE CAN
ULTIMATELY SADDLE ON A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF JUST HOW
INCREDIBLY DEVASTATING THAT'S
BEEN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITIES.
140 OFFICERS --
ON THE SAME.
DAY OUTSIDE OF 9/11, I CAN'T
THINK OF AN EVENT OR AN ATTACK
THAT RESULTED IN THAT MUCH
CARNAGE, DIRECTED SPECIFICALLY
AT OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
THAT, FOR STILL STRUGGLING WITH
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THAT LEGACY
IS.
IT'S SOMETIMES SEASONS THAT
HALF THE COUNTRY, HAVE THE
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN THE
COUNTRY, AND IS ON A PATH OF
LOOKING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY, AND
THE OTHER HALF IS STILL
DESPERATELY TRYING TO IGNORE
THINGS LIKE THOSE HUNDRED 40 --
ASSAULTS.
AND WASH THE